there wasn't a lot of information about
cannabis at the time and I was curious
if I just gave up everything I've worked
my whole life for for this plant I need
to understand more about this plan like
I ended up in the Himalayas in India oh
just seeing like like cannabis
growing like naturally in nature having
that experience it like changed
something for me to see it in its
natural habitat all this stuff we've
been told like it's kind of
when you see this is a plant and that
people have been using for thousands of
years for Spiritual purposes since I got
in trouble with the NFL my journey has
been really to bring this message to
whoever's willing to listen in my story
being a Heisman Trophy winner being a a
high achiever and utilizing cannabis to
help me do that I feel that's an
empowering story it's Redemption for all
of us all of us
and I started smoking and what it gave
me was perspective it allowed me to see
things differently and to make choices
that allow my life to be more meaningful
and this is I think what you guys are
doing helping people find more meaning
in their life yes foreign